you
what is up everybody welcome to yet
another Raspberry Pi tutorial in this
tutorial we're gonna be talking about
the terminal so the terminal is really
really important that you kind of use
and get used to because the Raspberry Pi
is very very powerful and most of the
things that you're going to use it for
or many of the things eventually you'll
be using your Raspberry Pi what's
referred to as headless so it's useful
to start learning these terminal
commands so later on you and start just
connecting via what's called SSH and not
have to you know come up with a screen
in a desktop like you'll connect from
another computer to this computer
basically so it is important that you
learn to use the terminal and just one
of things I find just beautiful about
the raspberry PI's is the fact that you
can't have a desktop you know like it'll
bring you to a desktop if you want that
and what's great is is for people who
aren't you know it's very comfortable
with using the terminal and stuff you
can at least start in an area of
familiarity you know that you can kind
of relate to this and then slowly ease
into losing your head literally and
going headless so with that let's go
ahead and hop in so open up your
terminal and again if you have not
overclocked my goodness you definitely
need to this is so much better once you
go over clump and let's just shape this
nicely sort of fit in our screen and
let's get started so basically what the
the terminal is is kind of like if you
know anything about your dos prompt it's
kind of like that and if you're
comfortable with the DOS prompt then
really you just need to learn the new
nomenclature and you'll be set otherwise
if you're not comfortable then that's
okay too this video should help you a
ton now from here you can pretty much do
everything that you can do on your
desktop by yourself you can pretty much
do everything within this little line
and what's lovely is like I was saying
you can connect via like SSH and
work on the computer and pretty much do
everything that you were once doing on a
desktop and once you get kind of
comfortable with it you'll actually just
get used to it's kind of like if you if
you've ever learned a program initially
you kind of had to like code like a line
test it code a line test it coda line
test it because you weren't really sure
if you got there like you're like
partially blind right but then as you
get used to it you can start going
pretty fast and you just start seeing
things differently you know and you can
kind of see it in your mind what you're
doing so so in a sense you're kind of
actually stepping back into really the
old way that people were using computers
and then people like Steve Jobs were
like hmm like we should really use
graphical and user interfaces so
everyone can use a computer but anyway
enough about that
let's start using this terminal so the
way you can kind of visualize the
terminal immediately is what you see
here right this is your current well
this is your user name right here
currently we are pie at Raspberry Pi but
this is your user name so currently it's
your user name and then where are we so
what we can do Who am I what we can do
to find out where we are just in case we
want to see the full directory path you
can do PWD and that tells us we're at
slash home slash PI that's where we
reside right now but another easy way to
kind of see where you are
that's probably used more often is
because generally you don't really care
where you are you care about where you
can go so LS and what that's going to do
is kind of list out all the things in
the directory that you're in right now
and so as we can see we've got a we have
a document or I mean a desktop documents
OCR API or OCR underscore PI dot PNG
anyway and so on you got Python gaming
scratch so the next thing that we can do
is if you want to dig a little further
you can do LS dash L a and you can list
out all of the files including hidden
files and the hidden files just have a
dot in front of them unlikely that
you'll ever really need to care about
that but sometimes you might and it also
just as a quick aside you know that's
not really security
you put dots in front of your files
because there they are actually very
visible but the next thing that we'll be
talking about now is like how do we go
from where we are now how do we go
forward right so that's what I said we
like to do so the way that you can do
that is using C D for change directory
and we'll go into the desktop make sure
you uppercase desktop and all that you
know the files whatever you're doing so
we'll see D in a desktop and sure enough
you can see that it's changed now it's
changed into desktop now if we do LS
we're gonna see something a little
different but I think it's just because
they're given like a desktop property
but you'll see what I'm talking about
every file here is dot desktop so it's
like a desktop modification to the file
so it's like on the desktop I don't
really know too much about what's going
on there I just know that obviously
something is going on there
so anyway let's see the let's say we
want to go back and check out documents
right so how do we get back so to see
these backwards you a period means where
you are and if another period means
backwards so if you want to go back in
directory you could just do dot dot or
you can do dot slash to be like really
really proper about things so we hit
enter and now we're back again so LS we
see okay we've got desktop document a
lot of stuff again so let's say we want
to now we want to CD in a document so
obviously that's how we do it so it's CD
documents and now we're in documents and
we can list out everything that's in
here and we see there's really only one
thing and that's scratched projects and
so now let's say we want to make our own
directory now to make a directory it's
actually pretty simple the command for
this is mkdir for making directory so
what we can do is it's going to make
this directory wherever you tell it so
right now our current folder is
documents so we can make the directory
straight into documents so that's
actually what we're going to do so we're
going to make a directory and we're
going to call it new dirt awesome camel
casing so make directory new dirt not
only lists out the directories we see
neuters
let's go in the CD into New York and
let's list everything nothing but what
about list list all sure enough we
actually have some other stuff in here I
have no idea what these things are but
they're there so anyway um continuing
right along sorry I left for a second I
believe we just left off going into new
der but anyway so now then we know how
to make directories how do we make files
well the command to make a file is touch
touch and given the name of that I have
absolutely no choice but to make the
file that we make this and we'll say
it's this dot txt for now so that makes
the files not only LS we can see we've
actually got this dot txt and if you
open up your file manager which you
could go to the rule bar here and go up
to accessories file manager or as you
can see they've aptly put it right here
so you just click on it and bring it up
so we are in documents neuter and sure
enough here's this dot txt awesome so
the next thing that we want to do is
let's say we want to edit this dot text
how do we do that well to open that up
you do the Nano this dot txt hit enter
and it will open up into your gnu man
and two point two point six awesome
so you can look like a baller as you
type stuff into here now so we'll just
say like example things something like
that now to save what you're gonna do
actually is just go ahead and say
control x for exit it will ask you if
you want to save the modified version y
for yes and it will already have the
name in there originally just hit enter
and that will save the file so now if we
actually you know by hand open up this
file we'll see there's example text in
there but also since we're awesome
people we can now just three nano into
this dot tex
and there is our example text already
there and we exit out of that
so the next thing though is really
you're probably stopped using touch to
just stop touching points you'll just
stop using that because actually what
you'll do like say you want to create
like the only few times I can think of
like if you want to make a directory a
lot of times that'll be empty but when
you make a file generally you're gonna
go ahead and start putting contents into
that file so the next thing is actually
instead of using touch why not let's
make a new file and we'll say Nano and
we're gonna call it PI script dot hi so
this obviously doesn't exist yet right
this is our new directory there's
nothing in there called this but what if
we nano that anyways sure enough here it
is and it actually already knows that
we're in a Python setting so because
we're you know you can see with the
little fancy colors so we can define
let's start finding stuff define main
free sub and then we'll go ahead and run
a mean wow so now we can just go ahead
and like no I guess we'll exit yes we'll
keep the name and so on so that's how
you make files and directories now what
if you want to maybe move the file like
right now it is in our new directory
what if we're like now let's move this
to documents right so how do we move the
file what's actually really quite simple
to move it into documents so it's cut
the move is just like CD only you're
going to specify what you're moving so
to move the file you'll say move and
what do we want to move the one with PI
script py and where do we want to move
it just back in directory let's say so
now we've done that we can open up new
directory and now we see we only have
this dot txt or python script has left
us but if we go back we can see oh
there's Python again awesome so it has
not totally
left us it just moved directories as we
wanted it to but now what if we want
what if we want it here but we also want
it in the new directory how do we do
that well next thing we want to do is
just copy the file so now we could say
copy and hmm trying to decide if I want
to do what I'm thinking of doing or not
well move and copy are basically the
same thing so if you were in or at least
like you know there's syntax for it
so right now PI script up py moved back
a directory right it's not in new
directory it's in documents right so if
we CD back and list out we didn't see
there's PI script WY but what if what if
you're in a directory and you want to
copy a thing out so we're kind of doing
two things at once so please bear with
me
but let's CD back into new directory and
now let's do copy CP what do we want to
copy we want to copy the file that's
back a directory called PI script dot py
where do we want to copy it if you
recall back to the beginning of the
tutorial I said a single period is where
you are now so it's kind of like a
shorthand way to just say here so we're
copying this thing back a directory
called PI script up py and we're company
here so we do that and sure enough let's
list out where we are so now we're in
new dirt there's PI script up py let's
CD back something
let's do list and there's PI script up
py again so two things at once
copy and then also the hole here but I
did already teach you guys here so this
should've been too difficult so now
let's say we do want this back
we want this in new dirt right we don't
want it in just documents right so here
we are in documents but we don't want it
in documents so how do we actually
delete this file so actually all you
have to do to do that is our M and what
do you want to delete PI scripts PI
script dot people
why now if you entered that command it
will work so we can enter it and now we
can LS and as you can see it's not here
anymore
and it's not here anymore but of course
it's still in new dirt but generally
kind of the best well there's two things
to learn from this one is first of all
there was no like are you sure you want
to delete it no right
like just deletes it so one thing to
kind of keep in mind when you're
deleting files and then what I'm about
to show you how to delete directories
it's gonna just delete it right and so
you sometimes what's best is to say
let's say you're in well it was
originally in document so you could say
PWD for a quick reminder of the full
path so instead of like let's say let's
nano let's Nano up high script up py
again real quick just so we have an
actual example here okay so we've got
just a simple little PI script
we're exited yes save the same thing so
now when we list a file there it is PI
script up you wider so the better way to
delete something would be using the full
path so instead of just RM and the file
name you can do RM slash home slash PI
slash documents / pi script dot p1
now again if we well I'm sorry he wanted
to pop over here but really the proper
way for me to show you is just with LS
now you can see the file got deleted and
using the full path was a much more much
safer way for you to start deleting
files because again it doesn't confirm
anything with you so you want to be kind
of certain that that's the file you
wanted to get rid of right because like
a lot of people might have files called
like main or you know I don't know some
other things that people have test files
like a lot of people have tests up high
or something like that that's like a
very similar name
for multiple files so the next thing is
like how do we actually delete a
directory so let's say we want to delete
new dirt so let's go ahead and do that
so the way to get rid of a directory is
again so we're in documents LS there's
meters so let's go ahead and just delete
new dirt or so we think
so our M dir is how you're gonna get rid
of a directory now you just put the
directory name in this case new dirt so
we hit enter and you see that actually
it failed because the directory is an
empty that is so very nice of them to
remind you of the dangers of RM yeah so
the way that you would delete that
directory is really you would want to
delete the directory plus everything in
it and there is a way to do this and
that is our M R and dash bar F and then
you want to say we're gonna do it to new
dirt so we will delete that directory
and as you saw it disappears from our
bar so now it's totally gone including
the files within it and the next thing
that you can kind of do I can't think of
too many scenarios where you'd want to
do it but it's it's a good little thing
to understand when it comes to deletion
so let's actually make a directory and
we'll call it a mother dirt and then we
want to do let's Nano another dirt and
the file will be another file dot txt
and let's say this is a text and we'll
control X Y to save it in order to save
it as that and then actually let's nano
another file so again 1 nano way even
though we're in documents we're actually
creating stuff in that other directory
even though we're residing and documents
we're telling it to make it in another
dirt so let's do that again
another dirt and now we're going to do a
pipeline of dot py
and we'll just make it a very simple
type I'll control X yes to save it enter
that keep the name and so now we
actually have two files so let's say we
want to do LS and I'm sorry well let's
see the into another car first and now
we'll do LS we've got two files within
another dirt so let's go back CD done
let's say instead what we'd rather do is
delete every file that ends in dot txt
in our another dirt how would we do that
well pretty simple we would say RM same
deletion tactic as before now we'll
specify the directory of another dirt
dat r / and these star and what the star
signifies is like all so if we just
leave the star in there it'll delete all
the files but we could also say
everything that and then ends in text so
if we hit enter here we'll CD into
another dirt LS and as we can see we've
still got a PI file but it did delete
our txt file now let's just nano a quick
text file real quick text dot txt Oh
ctrl X we're gonna save it say his name
so now we have a you know file system in
here
let's see you back a little more time
and now let's say we want to do our em
another dirt and then we just want to do
everything and then another dirt just
delete it all now let's CD into another
dirt
so we originally had two files the
Python file in the text file LS and as
you can see it is actually and what
about LS - la as you can see we did
retain our hidden files basically so
anyways or I don't even know if you're
in theory even hidden it might just be
like maintenance file or something on
I could try to delete some of the stuff
on our desktop but I'm not going to do
that for now anyway I think that will
conclude it as far as like basic stuff
like now you know how to at least copy
make directories move stuff around open
stuff edit stuff whatever
so that should at least help you to get
sort of comfortable with the idea of the
terminal so if you're still a little
uncomfortable keep playing around with
it there's a there like tons of commands
within the terminal and probably the
best stuff is the whole like get things
where you can just download things
offline it's very simple and you install
through the terminal and that's pretty
much the coolest stuff with this stuff
so anyway keep at it it's definitely
very worth while to learn it especially
for the SSH in the future and especially
if you plan to ever like operate a
server like a web server or just like
some other sort of servers so yeah
anyway hopefully you guys enjoyed it
hopefully you learn something as always
thanks for watching thank you for your
support and subscriptions and until next
time